so we partner with planet 13.  they have the space to accommodate this  huge drive  and we have vendors like greenlight  productions  as rov trendy medicine  nature's chemistry and so many others  that donated products  to make this happen it'll be going to  las vegas rescue mission  and safe nest oh the response has been  amazing we received over 30 000  cans toys and food perishables so we  decided to combine  everything and just do one huge drive  and after this we get to  wrap all the gifts and turn them into  all the children on december 19th these  are holiday times this is  2020 it's been a rough year for families  and everybody in las vegas  you know taking a hit with coven and  everything so we figured what way can we  give back more and we figured if we can  work well with  great partners we can really do  something magical and you know  having everybody donate over 30 000 cans  within two and a half weeks is unheard  of